recently I I had the opportunity to
spend a whole day with the legendary
people's court reporter Doug Llewelyn
the People's Court this is true I have a
lot of time the People's Court went off
the air last summer so Doug had a lot of
free time let's take a look a judge
Wapner seems like a very irascible
cantankerous guy is is he like that I
remember not too long ago a in a
Halloween party a costume party of Judge
Bob and his house I arrived in the door
open and there is judge Wapner and his
wife and they are dressed up like Mickey
and Minnie Mouse
there's judge Wapner in little red short
pants he's got a black t-shirt because
Mickey Mouse ears on his head he had the
best time at that party playing Mickey
Mouse told recently judge Ginsburg was
appointed to the Supreme Court by
President Clinton all right did judge
Wapner feel slighted did he feel like
he'd been passed over
I don't think so all I can tell you is
what the judge said he said he didn't
want to be on the Supreme Court he
didn't think he would have a ghost
chance of getting there hey if she naked
under that robe sometimes really but you
can't tell when I can tell but seriously
we have they have you kept up with rusty
since you've kept up with them because
we have a special surprise to you today
what's that rusty the bailiff right here
to say hi rusty rusty it's done how's it
going hey how are you Frank fine bracing
you here yeah what do you think God my
bad my bad
semi-closed you know what do you mean
this is rusty dude I better sneak out if
you would just go back to wherever you
came from
take care rusty he told me he was rusty
I'm sorry sure you can't believe
everything everybody tells you it's 12
years on the People's Court what was the
most remember her face real tribe I got
bitten by a dog once on camera and that
show caused a humongous outpouring of
cards and letters of sympathy wanting to
know how I was somebody had injured
their neighbor's dog and so the
neighbors filed a suit against them they
came to court the judge heard the case
and they won their lawsuit as they came
out they brought the dog with him the
dog is nervous okay it's a situation and
I'm standing there talking with with the
couple and the dog is and it was on a
watch on time the dog is looking at my
recap they could recap hello hello for
some reason rather I shifted my knee and
when he went
I watch a lot of daytime television now
and okay hang around the house and your
v-neck t-shirt why do you out of a can
no I haven't done if I'm going too far
no no I mean you're trying to make it
sound like it's really terrible it's
it's not that bad thank you guys thank
you you know what we're gonna take good
care of you okay so today we're gonna
help you re-enter the work community
take good care of you
trust me people walk out and you asking
questions just like on the show I mean
it should work you have a lot of
experience the only thing I haven't
worked out is who's gonna pay you hey
can I ask you a question were you
satisfied with the judge's decision you
weren't in a case I can ask you a quick
question
okay what'd you think of the judge's
decision what decision was that it was
only just hand in time I wasn't in the
judges chamber where you don't think of
the judges verdict what verdict just
happened which one inside and say where
Supreme Court building you just came out
of it what's the money my man why do you
have money in your mouth question what
did the judge what do you think of the
judges burning the one that just
happened inside were you guilty or
innocent for what what'd you do
we're in here why were you in the
Supreme Court over using the past
you're talking about I don't think you
should touch me yeah but think about it
from their perspective
you know you're grabbing them and
holding onto them help me right I didn't
come out of a cage take him out of a
courthouse
ya know what was going on in there I was
in there doing some business I'm a court
reporter here oh you're a court reporter
I'm a court reporter too
we can share skier on the People's Court
hey you know the People's Court remember
rusty yeah yeah you come across kind of
short on TV really that disappoints me
what do you think of rusty does he look
this good on TV he looks better in his
uniform I agree I think so too do you
need more court reporters in there yeah
we're real ones oh really you don't get
any realer than me no you're a reporter
I'm a court reporter
somebody wants your autograph that's
right these are negraph oh you want
Rusty's over Rusty's autograph from the
People's Court this is wonderful just be
giving your honor
there's a pen Mike quick word if you had
it to do over again would you do
anything differently no but you think he
beat rusty the bailiff today I thought
he was taller
sometimes I were you know thank you very
much good luck when I tell people that
he's rusty the bailiff
I don't think he should argue was it
what makes people happy
may I ask you a quick question if you
had anything to do differently would you
change it would you do anything over
again different yes I would what go back
to school longer good for you would you
like to meet Ross this is a stupid way
for me to make a living I apologize
everybody know why this is rusty the
bailiff I just you know recognizing yes
I do I do really yeah I recognize good
thank you very much
excuse me quick question I should quit
quick can you talk to me would you talk
to me and what is this it bad would you
like to meet rusty the bailiff me I'm
not a eunuch I don't particularly want
to meet rusty no you're the first person
I ever talked to that didn't want to
meet rusty everybody loves right Rusty's
are hurt you know this this isn't
working but I have another idea
I'm with him hi can I talk to you below
hi this one second chef did you should
do you like your lunch good very good
you satisfied with the outcome of your
meal yeah hi did you think the chef was
fair fair for what but what he gave you
for that price I think is okay very well
okay funky feel this is dead this is a
memorable experience for you this is
what I want you to meet rusty the
bailiff nice neutral hey I got to ask
you a question
I'll get this you watch here we go hi
step out what if I could ask you a quick
question do you think the driver treated
you fairly on this trip yeah anything as
a result of this experience well it's a
cat all to do over again would you do
anything differently well I think we
take a different in air condition you
know what you really like to would you
like to meet rusty the bailiff I'm sorry
I don't
[Applause]
I mean there's still time for you to get
a real estate license or something like
that I don't know it's just something to
think about I do believe that we're
getting there do you feel you were able
to beat the whizz whizz I file a lawsuit
against you for what
cuz you beat them all god bless you and
keep you mother
what do you think if you learned
anything for this experience
I did I really did yes I did
you're alright with me Conan thanks
I hope you'll be all right out there I
hope you'll be all right
[Applause]